your family lives in which part of Texas
North Texas Archer city okay do you get
no no no usually seven on the crowd will
fake it but I didn't even do you get you
get back home to visit much I do I do I
go home quite a bit and I love it
and I was just home and it was great and
they're having nice weather so they're
loving that cuz you know it's Tornado
Alley
so I think I told you that my mom for
her birthday wanted a fraidy whole did I
tell you that one time that sentence can
be taken so many ways she wanted a free
I don't know what a fraidy hole hey it's
a storm shelter Oh strong shelter okay
call it a fraidy Hall because it's where
you go when you're afraid
yeah and so I went home and I was like
opening up the door it's like all metal
like open up the doors I think you
brought a picture of the fraidy hole
that's like something on a loss that is
impressive the Dharma Initiative yeah
yeah yeah are you going I was just proud
that I knew a Dharma Initiative so
anyway I was like opening up the door
for it and my mom was like no no and I
was like why aren't you guys there's
spiders all in it maybe snakes I don't
know if they've had all this great
weather and they haven't been in it they
haven't cleaned out the fraidy hole yes
and so I'm sorry I got really excited I
said to my mom I was like mom I think
you need to clean out your afraid you
know
[Applause]
right now someone you're somewhere your
grandmother's watching she's I don't
like it Tama yes I'm out
you